airport arrivals has a new look
this is heathrow's answer to post-travel
quarantine
when i get ready i want you to check off
the market the boss was the first to
visit this new testing facility
passengers can book to be swabbed on
arrival and then take a second test home
with them
if both are negative two weeks in
quarantine could be halved
quick and easy yes thank you perhaps but
it still needs the government to agree
this is something for number 10 to
really get a grip on and give us the
green light to go ahead with testing
testing is a very good way of making
sure that people don't have covid
it's what we rely on with the nhs
workers and if it's good enough for the
nhs it should be good enough
for visitors to this country it's
aviation seizing the initiative
an embattled industry fighting back
there's evidence double testing with
five days in between reduces the risk of
false negatives
but there's potential pitfalls and
political caution
the challenge is because the virus can
incubate inside your body
without coming forward and without
therefore a test being positive even if
you've got it
um the challenge is how to do that
testing
in a way that uh that we can have
confidence
enough in to release the quarantine
but ramping up testing is the plan
better technology
quicker results and more tests for those
without symptoms
a program to test the spread amongst
those who aren't ill will be scaled from
28 to 150 000 the majority of people who
turn up to a testing center like this
are showing signs of having the virus
but random testing samples done by the
ons showed that just 28
of infected people actually showed any
symptoms it's why experts say
mass testing is so vital it's the only
way to catch those asymptomatic carriers
a slow start to testing bought fierce
criticism but the uk fares better now
with an average
of 2.37 daily tests per thousand people
just ahead of the us it's better than
our european neighbors germany france
and spain
all currently running fewer than 1.3
tests per thousand
but it trails global leaders such as the
uae new zealand and denmark
critics say the logistics still need
work we are running out of time and
that's why it's
it's it's very urgent now we're only
using about half the testing capacity we
have now
so one of the things we suggest is as
you build up
to mass testing using all the available
lab
facilities and these new rapid on the
spot tests
that we we also engage in using
the testing capacity we've already got
in order to to test more groups of
people
clearly there's work still to do but
testing more people in more places
perhaps
our way out of this crisis
helen smith sky news